Here it is. H of x equals 5 to the x. But what points lie on this function?
Let's figure it out. Here's a table for you to fill out, so that we can
organize this information well. However, in order to do this, you're probably
going to need to use a calculator. Since the numbers are going to get really
big, really fast. If you don't own a calculator, it's easy to find one online
by searching for scientific calculator. And if you do have your own scientific
calculator. It should have a button that makes evaluating exponential functions
very simple. In fact, Google makes a calculator that's very easy to find and
very easy to use. Here it is. It comes up right when you search scientific
calculator on Google. This is what I'll be using today to do our calculations.
As you can see, this calculator has a button that says x to the y on it. Now if
I want to calculate six to the third power, for example, I would press 6. Then
I would press x to the y. And then I would press three. You can see that the
calculator is showing us 6 to the 3rd. When I press equals, that gives me the
number that's equal to, which is 216. Let's try another one. Maybe I want to
find four to the negative fifth. Well, I press four, then our lovely x to the y
button, and then I type negative 5. Great, I see 4 to the negative 5th, which
is what we're looking for. Pressing Enter tells me that it's this long
exponent. Let's practice using that button on our calculator to find different
points on this function. For each value of x, I've written here, please fill in
the corresponding value of h of x. In other words find 5 to the x for each of
these x values.